happy Wednesday everybody how you doing
all right all right all right oh you
guys are great
so Democrats are freaking out that they
peaked too early with just weeks to go
before the midterms their celebrations
were so premature it reminds me of prom
night
I know
I wish the election was in August said
one Democrat as they watched their
momentum fade like an electric car
trying to get up a hill and the polls
have Republicans pulling away like Leo
DiCaprio from a woman who just turned
26.
because he likes him young that's the
joke in case you missed it all right
even the New York Times sees a swing in
Independent Women which reminds me of
the trapeze above Larry kudlow's hot tub
yeah
huh is that creeping you out all right
of course this pains The View who
expected something so different it's
like they they were given a generic
adult diaper instead of their favorite
brand
here's Joy sounding more miserable than
usual that voters are more focused on
inflation and crime and not her usual
obsessions like January 6th and fright
wigs
but what's depressing is that the New
York Times released a poll today that
says that 71 percent of Voters agree
that democracy is under threat yeah
percent of Voters uh rank a threat to
democracy as a major issue this election
cycle yeah I find that so depressing I
can't begin to tell you well I don't
like polls
talk about racist no pierogies for you
whoopee
no surprise though rather than focusing
on that people care about they went all
in on Jan 6 failing to realize that a
slick PowerPoint presentation on Trump
Hitler does nothing to lower prices cut
crime or seal the border the only people
who actually watched were the CNN
producers currently in jail
all it did is provide masturbation
fodder for anchors at MSNBC and God
knows they need it
your Trend the wokesters are now
realizing their BS no longer flies
wokism has fizzled out like a
three-week-old bottle of ginger ale and
how do I know well when the woke become
the fodder on Dr Phil
who is my second favorite doctor after
Dr Jill
I like her because she dresses like my
aunt's sofas
so here's a sad group suggesting
punishment for comedians
why are comedians not even willing to
come on college campuses anymore because
they're scared to death they're going to
say something that offends the
stereotypes used in comedic stand up is
just simply just like not okay anymore
so you can say whatever you want but you
need to be also be ready for like the
repercussions of what you say I think
that while social repercussions are
nothing new what we penalize people for
saying is changing and I think that
that's a positive thing
[Music]
it is a positive thing but for a
different reason you dope
you know wokism has hit the wall when
its proponents are treated like Sideshow
freaks on an afternoon talk show
in case you forgot afternoons in the 80s
and 90s they were made for this
[Applause]
in the case of four-month-old Mariah
Raphael you are not
those
[Music]
[Laughter]
those were the days
sadly those people could be running on a
Democrat ticket and would do well today
back then bearded ladies were Carnival
acts now they're on school boards
but once you enter that phase and end up
on an afternoon talk show you're no
longer something serious you're the
funniest thing on earth and these people
are truly unintentionally hilarious
their demands combined with zero life
skills turn them into baby Jerry
falwells funny it used to be the old
folks who railed against culture but
that's flip now it's the young instead
of don't trust anyone over 30 now you
can't trust anyone under 30 at least to
take a joke or pay their bills or listen
to another point of view
woksters think everything that came
before them was bigoted but I can tell
you right now that's garbage you know
here's a brief sample of some of the
shows that I watched as a kid
what's making headlines today dear oh
honey
stupid [ __ ] don't you know news is a
man's concern now why don't you get back
to the kitchen where you belong
[Music]
okay everybody it's a very exciting day
we get to meet our new boss James
Washington what's up how do you do oh
what it is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's how it used to be
if you believe the woke but the tide is
turning you got Barack Obama urging
Democrats to stop murdering Joy
and my family my kids
you know work that gives me satisfaction
uh you know having fun
you know you know not not being a buzz
kill and sometimes Democrats are right
it's it's like you know sometimes you
know people just want to not feel as if
they are
walking on eggshells
took them a while to get there but
oh
I miss that huh you have States and
companies denouncing ESG as shareholders
discover woke investing is as smart as
funding Alec Baldwin's next movie
oh what's with this audience she's
Louise
trying to do something about wokeism and
you guys are thinking everything's in
bad taste
you have woke products failing from
comic books bent and identity politics
to movies lecturing us on social issues
that came and went like Billy eichner's
flick Bros
which is coming to a dumpster near you
or on
what what do you mean I don't now your
laugh at that makes no sense and have
you seen a woke comedian lately I
haven't the late night shows always so
careful to tow the PC line or dropping
like Biden's dentures in a
trick-or-treaters bag so I'm optimistic
when a political movement is now a
freakish curiosity that's a good thing
and when Obama is sick of cancel culture
that's even better my suggestion to the
woke it's time to turn over a new Leaf
smile take a shower work out try to get
laid these are all four things I
accomplished at Planet Fitness yesterday
and talk to people not about politics
hell try the weather not everything has
to be a class struggle when someone says
to you it's a beautiful day don't say
hmm not if you're trans
try saying you're right it feels like
fall Small Talk actually bonds people
won't talk rips them apart and maybe
watch this show a few times a week and
see how fun is done correctly because if
you're young there's still time for you
to kick some ass in this world instead
of whining like a little [ __ ] it's time
to start thinking of an exit strategy
from cancel culture to maybe canceling
cancel culture itself
[Applause]
for Halloween he'll be dressing as a
grown-up host of The Guy Benson show Guy
Benson
foreign
than Brian stelter at the Country Buffet
actor comedian and host of the Harland
Highway podcast Arlen Williams
she's like sunglasses useful stylish but
often left behind in a hotel bathroom
Fox News contributor captain
[Applause]
and finally he once bumped his head on
the International Space Station my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Television Champion Tyrus
Harland I am beyond pleased that you're
here thank you buddy what a treat is it
really treat I'm happy to be here we've
been trying to working on this for a
long time a long time and now it's it's
beyond a treat it's a cinnamon treat yes
yeah very tasty yeah a lot of icing on
that yeah yeah let it cool after the
microwave though oh sweet and sour smog
Grace yes it's delicious yeah I like the
smear it on my chest oh wow okay okay
yeah yeah we'll leave the light on for
you yes
has uh what do you make it has this
affected your comedy at all did you have
to change your material you've been
doing this for probably 35 years maybe
right yeah I've been doing stand-up 35
years and it hasn't changed my material
because I think what a lot of the woke
cultures missing is they're assuming
that if we do a bit or a joke about a
culture or or a sexual preference or
anything like that they immediately
think maybe we're attacking it or we're
going after it but what they don't
realize is a lot of time we're doing it
for that specific group recognizing that
every group has a sense of humor and
you're hoping in your head let's say you
do a gay joke or a joke about A
different race you're hoping that those
guys at home going oh that's hilarious
I'm glad he did a joke about something
that represents who I am exactly by the
way you're basically saying welcome to
the club that's right and by not doing
jokes about it you're eliminating those
people and you know
disenfranchising them even more and
removing them from the pool I did a set
not too long ago where I was talking
about uh transgenders and some guy in
the front row lit me up and he goes oh
easy topic to make fun of and I said I'm
not making fun of it idiot I'm trying to
include you yeah in the routine hoping
you'd find humor in hearing something
about yourself so is he Trans in the
audience or she trans well you know what
happened his brother uh tweeted me later
and said he wasn't even trans he was
just looking to cause trouble so I I
said hey if you're going to be that woke
let me take you to Walmart I'll buy a
Walmart sleeping bag and I'll zip it all
the way up and you can go back to sleep
you woke freak
thank you
that's an interesting use of a Walmart
sleeping bag I must say you know guy as
someone who gets all their views from
the view uh do you think inflation is
more or less important than democracy I
mean it is amazing and you alluded to it
in the monologue how incredibly joyless
that woman is and her name is Joy yeah
she's she's an expert on depression and
sadness and frustration and I think that
you don't really understand how fully
out of touch you are until you go on
national television and whine to your
like-minded rich friends that these
annoying unwashed masses care about what
things cost instead of your particular
pet issue it's just a complete lack of
understanding of how most people live
which is I think on brand for that show
and on the woke stuff Barack Obama with
all due respect was like the lecturer in
Chief for eight years he would look down
his nose and deliver these lectures to
the country and if even he is tired of
the exhausting woke culture he's like
hey like chill out and maybe have some
fun these guys are way out there but
they're not going to stop until they're
beaten like we have to actively beat
them and I feel like this show does that
every night yes
but I have to just point out we do not
Advocate violence
sometimes there are times we will
Advocate violence cat you Advocate
violence all the time you're very Pro
violence sure yes exactly
um um do you buy that that's going away
are you ready to forgive your woke
friends who disowned you I don't think
they want me back that's how disowning
Works yes
uh I don't I don't think people who
benefit from this want to give it up
because I think the idea is they get to
say okay I just want to be ever be
sensitive I don't want anyone to hurt my
feelings I don't think that's always
true I think there's people that can't
wait to have their feelings hurt because
when their feelings hurt that gives them
power over other people just by simply
existing yeah so I this Dr Phil thing
which I watched all of it of course Dr
Phil is great I remember maybe a home
that's like sick from school and be like
wow these people are nuts uh it's
um they don't want to give that up and
they're going to continue to do that
it's not about wanting to feel included
it's wanting to be in your own protected
class that gives you power over other
people and the ability to shut down
other people's speech oh you know that
just scared me Tyrus what Kat is
suggesting is that what something worse
will come along that's what you just
said you said that it really does go
away sounds on brand for me yeah it does
they're going to up their victim game
yes exactly you know I I do feel for uh
Joy yes you know she worked hard with
her team for the last two years you know
January 6th they put a lot of time and
effort into that episode after episode
tweet after tweet and they only get a
lousy seven percent
what are you watching come on people
this I would be feared think about that
yes I spent all that time and energy yes
working making up just going and seven
percent I might have cried on TV yeah
you know and so I feel for them you know
because they're not out of touch like
guy said the unwashed masses just don't
get it so obviously
We're Not Gonna rethink things we're
gonna turn it up we got to get an extra
hour on The View you know we got to get
more of the woke people on TV and we got
to have more Twitter videos of hearing
people try to explain their pronouns to
normal functioning human beings and it
not be hilarious why they're telling it
you know when I hear that one we're like
one was saying her pronoun was God and
god-like because
it is a being and not a being I'm here
and I'm not here which is very similar
to God and then he said are you here now
which
it said you can't ask me that hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else